امبراطوريتان عسكريتان قامتا على انقاض
حكم البشير رجلان الحكم العسكري في
السودان نفايا مرارا وجود اي خلاف بينهما
وحجم التراشق الكلامي في خانه حرب زائفه
ابتدعت اعلاميا بهدف خرق الصف الواحد الا
انه منزلق للمواجهه المسلحه
رئيس مجلس السياده الانتقالي في السودان
عبد الفتاح البرهان قائد القوات البريه في
عهد البشير صار قائدا للجيش النظامي فيما
اسس الثاني اي محمد حمدان دقلو المعروف
بحمدتي قوات الدعم السريع معتمدا
عالميليشيا خاضت حربا داميه في دارفور
لكنه لم يعد يرضى بلقب الرجل الثاني في
الدوله او النائب
تهديد فعلي شكله احمدتي للبرهان معززا
امبراطوريته بجيش خاص قوامه 100 الف عنصر
اي ما يوازي تقريبا حجم قوات الجيش
السوداني فضلا عن تكسب اقتصادي نتج عن عقد
صفقات مع شركات دوليه
في الاتفاق الايطالي اداه للمحافظه على
مكتسباته لكن التوقيع فشل مرتين بسبب
خلافات حول دمج قوه الدعم السريع في الجيش
ومداه الزمني ووضعيه قياده القوات ففي حين
اراد البرهان اتمام الدمج وفقا لقواعد
الجيش وانظمته تمسك احمدتي باعاده هيكله
قياده الجيش العليا اولا حتى يكون جزءا
منها قبل دمج قواته وتقليص نفوذه نازل
احب
احسن نمشي
قضايا خلافيه اخرى شقت طريقها الى
المنظومه الامنيه مثل اصلاح الجيش وابعاد
انصار النظام السابق عنه كما مثلت اداره
الملفات الخارجيه ونسج نائب البرهان
لعلاقات عابره للحدود تحديا كبيرا
للجانبين فحملتي متهم من قبل الجيش بخلق
علاقات دبلوماسيه موازيه للدوله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات